if you followed Apple's recent
developments with the iPhone you would
have seen augmented reality or AR gaming
and action
now I got my hands on the game that was
demoed on stage called the machine
shortly after the event and while I
wouldn't say it's exactly revolutionary
it does set the stage for something
bigger if you want more on the tech that
drives the games we love make sure you
stick to GameSpot for more game tech so
onto a our gaming through a phone with
the launch of iOS 11 developers are now
delivering AR games in the mobile space
with AR kit it's essentially a toolset
that streamlines the creation process
for AR games on the Apple platform now I
spent my day with the machines and it
plays similarly to a MOBA games such as
heroes of the storm or dota 2 and now
you control characters with a set of
abilities on a map with specific lanes
mechanics are similar to that of an
action RPG in this game you control two
characters which adds to how hectic
battles can get it actually gets you up
and moving throughout a match now we all
need some exercise right the catch here
is that with AR the map is placed in the
real world as long as you have the
proper space and table for the game
surrender and it was seamless to setup
you have to walk around the map move in
and out and get the best view to make
strategic decisions and pull off
abilities at the perfect moment I found
myself splitting my characters off into
two lanes for a sort of pincer attack
and I ended up running back and forth
between the two ends of the table to
make sure that everyone was doing what I
needed them to do it's one of my
highlights with the machines since I was
playing pre-launch I didn't get to
experience the local or online
multiplayer but when I extract my
single-player experience and think about
playing with friends I could see the
excitement of crowding around the same
table and getting rambunctious in a
competitive match I also got to play
zombie gunship revenant also developed
with AR kit it's a wave based shooter
from the perspective of a helicopter
making sure your base doesn't get
overrun when you activate the camera
though you can place your base anywhere
as if it's a set of toys in the real
world as someone who isn't big on mobile
games it's hard not to think of AR as a
novelty but it's still in its early
stages I mean you look at what Pokemon
go did granted it's a huge IPE paired
with its core concept built around
physically going places to capture
Pokemon so now the door is open even
wider for another gaming experience like
that now one of the attractions of a are
compared to VR in the gaming space is
that the barrier to entry is lower you
just need the proper phone and the
proper space as opposed to a headset
sensors and a powerful system but
they're inherently different experiences
new challenges come up with AR like
battery life thermal limitations and the
control scheme but that shouldn't hold
developers back from trying to push
mobile AR Gaming forward augmented
reality isn't entirely new but with this
new platform integration through iOS
with AR kit there's potential for some
really unique gaming experiences as a
our gaming something you find exciting
or you're more curious about now let us
know in the comments if you want to see
more stuff like this thanks for watching
and we'll see you soon